Was ist los beim Rasenfunk, wir werden es euch sagen und zu Gast habe ich natürlich den lieben Frank.
Da lach ich mir doch einen Arsch ab.
Echt. Alles bla bla bla ist das doch. Alles bla bla bla ist das.
Das Tribünengespräch.
Zeit für einen Klassiker, aber im neuen Gewand und sogar mit Code Opener. Hallo liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Servus Frank. Wir wollen sprechen über den Rasenfunk und was wir so getan haben im letzten Jahr. Unser kurzes Update und so weiter. Oft durch Hörerinnen Fragen getrieben. Warum haben wir uns denn diesmal gegen die Community entschieden, Frank?
Rechtfertige Dinge? Na, haben wir natürlich gar nicht. Aber wir haben gesagt, wir wollen das im Winter jetzt ein bisschen kompakt halten. Wir hatten auch unser Treffen, unsere Drei-Königs-Klausur, quasi nicht an drei König, aber erst vor zwei Tagen. Und darum haben wir gesagt, jetzt machen wir ein kompaktes Update. Versuchen so ein bisschen die Sachen reinzubringen, die ohnehin sehr oft auftauchen in den Fragen. Und dann können wir zum Saisonende wieder ein bisschen mehr, naja, detaillierter darauf eingehen, was dann wirklich noch anfällt und so. Und haben wir gesagt, das ist vielleicht die bessere Variante. Auch damit wir ein bisschen kompakter bleiben, weil für dich, Max, steht schon der nächste Termin an.
Jaja, klar. Freue mich schon. Ja, aber du weißt natürlich, also jetzt hast du dreimal das Wort kompakt verwendet, vielleicht sogar viermal. Du weißt, dass der Running Gag des Rasenfunks ist, dass ich immer sage, heute wird es eine kürzere Sendung und dann schreiben die Leute drunter, sag dir, er und vier Stunden Sendung folgten.
Naja, also, wollen wir mal sehen. Heute wird es definitiv, um beim Intro zu bleiben, nur bla bla bla.
Es geht nicht um Fußball, nur in Nebendingen. Also wir wollen euch auf den Stand bringen, wie hat sich so das letzte Jahr entwickelt und wie ihr es eben gerade schon gehört habt. Wahrscheinlich wird es so sein, dass es so eine Sendung jetzt dann immer so alles halbe Jahr mal gibt oder zweimal im Jahr ist wahrscheinlich richtiger. Das heißt, es gibt auch definitiv das nächste Mal wieder die Möglichkeit, für euch Fragen zu stellen. Frank, wir wollen Bilanz ziehen, passt ja auch ganz gut an den Beginn eines neuen Jahres, dass man es auf das letzte nochmal zurückblickt und unter anderem wollen wir Bilanz ziehen mit Blick auf die Feed-Umstellung. Im Grunde war es die größte Veränderung, glaube ich, die wir je im Rasenfunk gemacht haben.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ja genau, das war natürlich, wir haben jetzt bei unserer Klausur vor zwei Tagen auch nochmal drüber gesprochen, weil wir fast am gleichen Ort saßen als damals, als die legendäre Entscheidung fiel, letztes Jahr im Mai. Und dann haben wir zum Saisonwechsel die Feeds umgestellt und eigentlich muss ich erstmal sagen, vielleicht ein bisschen, soll jetzt gar nicht so sehr nach Eigenlob klingen, aber ich war ganz begeistert, dass wir es hinbekommen haben, weil daran haben wir im Mai noch ein bisschen gezweifelt.
Ja, wenn du sagst, es ist Eigenlob, ich möchte sagen, ich war begeistert, dass wir es hinbekommen haben, weil du, Frank, zusammen mit unserem Programmierer da sehr hart dran arbeiten musstest und mit Tobias.
Genau, und das war dann parallel zu meinem Umzug und so, also es war gar nicht wirklich klar, wird das alles klappen zum Saisonstart, die Website fertig zu haben, die ja dann doch nicht nur die neuen Feeds bekommen hat, sondern gleich noch so ein bisschen ein kleines Redesign. Und ja, das war erstmal, glaube ich, der erste wichtige Schritt und dann ist natürlich die Feed-Umstellung passiert und wir wussten etwas, was hat das jetzt für Folgen. Verlieren wir irgendwie Hörer, kriegen wir zum Beispiel den Nationalmannschaftsfeed, kriegen wir den als neuen Feed ordentlich bekannt gemacht, dass er auch genutzt wird, klappt es mit der Auslagerung der Frauensendungen in den eigenen Feed, was wir eigentlich ja nie wollten, weil wir immer gesagt haben, wir wollen nicht, dass es irgendwie so extra ist, wir wollen, dass es mehr Aufmerksamkeit bekommt und unterm Strich müssen wir aber sagen und das war unser Fazit vor zwei Tagen, wir sind eigentlich superglücklich damit und hat ganz gut funktioniert, oder?
Also es war technisch ein wirklich, du musstest da sehr, sehr viel ackern und wir mussten dann nochmal händisch irgendwie jede Episode nochmal zuordnen. Also ich habe nochmal fast jede Episode nochmal anfassen müssen, das waren schon dann doch einige, aber die Zahlen und das ist natürlich das einzige, worauf wir gucken, Frank, wir sind ja bekannt dafür, als diejenigen, die nur nach Zahlen operieren, aber die zeigen eben, das hat alles ganz gut geklappt, also wenn man mal die Feed so nacheinander durchgeht, es folgt jetzt ein kleines Referat, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, Frank hat es schon am Dienstag bekommen, wir nehmen hier am Donnerstag den 11. Januar auf. Also die Bundesliga der Männer, da haben wir ja vor allem die Aufteilung in Spieltagssendungen und in Schwerpunktsendungen gehabt, die inhaltlich finde ich sehr, sehr gut funktioniert, es gab auch sehr viel positives Feedback, einige wenige denen fehlt es dann doch die Interaktion im Schwerpunkt, die allerdings gar nicht immer da war, also ich glaube, das ist ein bisschen auch Verklärung der Vergangenheit, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, denn ich habe da sehr, sehr genau drauf geachtet die letzten zwei Jahre, bevor es zu dieser Ausgliederung kam, denn ich hatte das ja schon sehr lange als Idee oder wir beide haben da schon sehr früh drüber gesprochen, tatsächlich eine Interaktion des zweiten Gastes mit dem Schwerpunktgast, die gab es gar nicht so häufig, wie man denkt, häufig war es dann eher so, dass ich dann den Gast noch mit reingeholt habe, damit er oder sie einfach mal wieder was sagen darf. Und ob das dann inhaltlich immer so vorantreibend war, das liegt 0, 0 an den Gästen, sondern natürlich daran, dass ich mir irgendeine Frage aus der Nase gezogen habe, das war dann doch nicht so. Aber inhaltlich hat diese Trennung meiner Meinung nach sehr gut funktioniert, vor allem deshalb, weil es klar verständlich ist für alle Beteiligten und weil die Schwerpunkte eine viel längere Haltbarkeit haben. Die hatten sie schon immer, also man kann jetzt noch wunderbar zum Beispiel den Mainz 05 Schwerpunkt hören mit Mara Pfeiffer oder auch viele andere, den Heidenheim Schwerpunkt zum Beispiel, den kann man wahrscheinlich sogar in drei Jahren noch hören, weil da sehr viel die Geschichte Heidenheims bis zum Ausstieg hin erzählt wird. Und das war schon immer so bei den Schwerpunkten, es wusste nur ehrlich gesagt außer uns keiner und außer denjenigen, die den Schwerpunkt gehört haben. Und ich hoffe, dass...
Und wenn ich dich unterbrechen darf, da kommt noch ein Aspekt dazu, wenn die Hörer sich erinnern, die, die im Forum aktiv sind, vor allem mitmachen rasenfunk.de für alle, die es nicht sind bisher, bitte registriert euch da, macht mit. Da haben wir ja vorab diskutiert, was können wir am Rasenfunk ändern, um ihn vorwärts zu bringen, um ihn bekannter zu machen und so. Und da war ja ein Thema und das hat sich da in den Schwerpunkten, finde ich, ganz gut abgezeichnet, ist diese bessere Aufwendbarkeit. Nämlich, dass jetzt dieser Schwerpunkt wirklich als Thema mit vielleicht auch einer entsprechenden Catchy Headline dazu bei YouTube als eigenes Video auftaucht, darüber auffindbar ist, in den Podcatchern als eigene Folge auftaucht und nicht unter Spieltag XY und in Klammer irgendwie Schwerpunkt Heidenheim. Das ist, glaube ich, ein ganz großer Gewinn, der auch auf diese langfristige Haltbarkeit einzahlt, die du gerade erwähnt hast, Max.
Aber fehlen dir die Wortspiele, Frank?
Also mir persönlich nicht.
Mir tut es manchmal noch weh, ich muss es so ehrlich zugeben, aber das gehört eben zur Wahrheit mit dazu. Keiner hat es verstanden. Also egal, wie kreativ das Wortspiel war, dann daraus rauszulesen, nur die Rasenfunk-HörerInnen wussten dann, ah, anhand des Wortspiels kann ich erkennen, um wen der Schwerpunkt sich dreht. Das hat ansonsten niemand verstanden und da hat sich die Podcastlandschaft auch verändert, dass Aufwendbarkeit noch schwieriger geworden ist als früher, dadurch, dass einfach jetzt jeder Wald- und Wiesenverlag ein Podcast hat und nicht nur so große Unternehmen wie wir.
Und das war tatsächlich einer der Argumente, die auch im Forum kamen. Also das war so ein Input, der uns da auch ein bisschen bestärkt hat, dass das durchaus im Forum eigentlich ein bisschen überraschend für mich kam. Ich dachte, dass unsere Stammhörer sich eher an diesen Dingen festhalten, so ein bisschen. Aber da kamen relativ klar einige Punkte, die uns aufgezeigt haben, okay, selbst die eigene Community denkt, dass das nicht gerade dazu beiträgt, dass der Rasenfunk gut gefunden und vor allem für Einsteiger einfach zu handeln ist.
Absolut. Und das hat auch die Entscheidung für uns einfacher gemacht, dass es da diese sehr, sehr gute Diskussion im Forum gab. Also vielen Dank dafür nochmal an alle Beteiligten. Was man allerdings sagen muss, du hast es jetzt schon erklärt, die Aufwendbarkeit ist besser geworden, es erklärt sich auch eher von selbst, um was sich eine Sendung dreht. Also das eine ist eben einfach Analyse des Spieltags und das andere ist dann ein größeres Gespräch zu einem Team. Was allerdings noch nicht passiert ist, wäre, dass sich irgendetwas davon in Zahlen ausgedrückt hätte. Tatsächlich ist es aktuell noch so, die Analysesendungen zum Spieltag haben mehr Downloads als die zu den Schwerpunkten. Es geht nicht weit auseinander, aber beides ist noch deutlich zu unterscheiden. Und das zeigt eben, dass das, was wir jetzt gerade gesagt haben, nämlich die größere Haltbarkeit und dass man so etwas jetzt auch mal etwas leichter jemandem hinwerfen kann, der den Rasenfunk vielleicht noch nicht kennt, dass das so ein bisschen vielleicht ein Auftrag an euch ist, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Das kann man jetzt vielleicht viel, viel besser machen. Also postet solche Sendungen in Foren, schickt sie über den Messengerdienst eurer Wahl an Fans des jeweiligen Vereins. Also man kann jetzt wieder sehr, sehr viel einfacher, glaube ich, für den Rasenfunk Werbung machen und das auch, wenn der Schwerpunkt schon eine Weile vorbei ist. Also ich glaube, eigentlich müsste sich das irgendwann drehen, denn die Analysesendungen werden natürlich auch deswegen von so vielen Menschen gehört, weil, so ehrlich muss man sein, sich manche da auch einfach nur den Part zu ihrem Verein rauspicken. Nicht jeder von diesen, keine Ahnung, 25.000, 30.000, müsste ich jetzt nochmal in die Zahlen gucken, irgendwo so umdreherum, hört dann die komplette Sendung. Bei den Schwerpunkten allerdings ist es dann schon erstaunlich, dass auch unabhängig vom Verein, also es ist nicht so, dass der Bayern-Schwerpunkt irgendwie 40.000 Downloads hätte, sondern ganz im Gegenteil, der ist sogar deutlich unter manchem anderen Schwerpunkt. Eigentlich liebe ich das ja sogar, dass der große FC Bayern da jetzt nicht zieht und dass irgendwie 100.000 Leute hören. Das bestärkt unseren kompletten Ansatz. Aber natürlich wissen wir, es gibt da draußen sehr viele Fans, die den Rasenfunk noch nicht kennen oder die den Rasenfunk vielleicht mal gehört haben und dann gemerkt haben, boah ey, das dauert mir viel zu lang, das ist mit so unspezifisch bla bla bla. Was man da alles sagen kann, ja auch durchaus zu Recht. Also ich wollte es jetzt nicht abwerten mit dem bla bla bla. Also seht es als Auftrag, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, den Rasenfunk bekannter zu machen. Teilt uns, wo immer ihr könnt. Ansonsten müssen wir sagen, Bundesliga der Männer, das funktioniert gut. Wir haben jetzt natürlich mehr Sendungen dadurch. Vom Aufwand der Gästefindung und so weiter ist ein bisschen was dazugekommen. Aber dazu gibt es große Neuigkeiten, die werdet ihr später in dieser Sendung hören, damit man auch merkt, wie gut ich inzwischen im Teasern geworden bin. Also Bundesliga der Männer, dieser Feed funktioniert sehr gut. Sehr gespannt waren wir darauf, wie würde dann der neue Feed der Bundesliga der Frauen angenommen werden. Und zugegeben, der Feed hatte vor allem deshalb Startprobleme, weil der am längsten nach der Umstellung nicht befüllt wurde. Während es beim Nationalteam einfacher war, da Menschen hineinzuziehen und eine Sichtbarkeit auch zu bekommen, war das beim Bundesliga der Frauen Feed viel, viel, viel schwieriger, weil wir den Feed eingerichtet haben. Da lagen dann auch schon alte Folgen drin. Aber bis eine neue dazukam, nämlich die Bundesliga Vorschau, das hat ein paar Monate gedauert. Und da hatte ich durchaus meine Bauchschmerzen, weil ich immer, ich hab schon überlegt, kann ich da irgendwas reinschieben, irgendwie was Aktuelles. Aber ich hätte es ja gar nicht geschafft, es aufzuzeichnen. Aber wir müssen sagen, es funktioniert sehr, sehr gut. Die Downloadzahlen sind geringer als bei den Männern, zum Teil auch deutlich geringer. Aber wir sehen eine Entwicklung. Wir bekommen inhaltlich sehr, sehr gute Rückmeldung und vor allem die Sichtbarkeit ist sehr gut. Also ich habe jetzt auch im Nachhinein den Gedanken gehabt, Frank, wir wollten, dass beides nicht trennen, Bundesliga Männer, Bundesliga Frauen, weil wir damit eine Gleichwertigkeit unbedingt darstellen wollten. Und ironischerweise könnte man aber auch sagen, durch die Trennung haben wir eine Gleichwertigkeit geschaffen. Denn du gehst bei uns auf die Seite und du siehst als erstes Bundesliga Männer, als zweites Bundesliga Frauen. Und seine eigene Farbe. Die Farben sind wunderschön. Danke nochmal an Tobi. Also sprich, der Frauenfeed läuft gut an, er wächst. Auch hier natürlich der Hinweis, sehr, sehr gerne weiter teilen. Auch sehr gerne im Bereich der Frauenbundesliga Gäste Vorschläge schicken. Das ist bisher ein fester Pool, den ich auch liebe. Ich liebe jeden einzelnen Gast, den wir im Rasenfunk haben. Aber natürlich wollen wir da auch weiter neue Stimmen mit hinzunehmen. Ich habe hin und wieder Hinweise bekommen in der Hinrunde. Da hatte ich allerdings das Problem, dass es waren ja 60 Sendungen zwischen September und Dezember und ich hatte dann einfach nicht mehr die Kraft und Zeit auch, neue Gäste mit in den Rasenfunk reinzuholen. Weil das bedeutet eben immer, erklären wie es läuft, Honorarvereinbarung, Technik klären und so weiter und so fort. Das ist einfach ein Mehraufwand, der nicht ging. Jetzt in der Rückrunde nehme ich mir das wieder vor. Das heißt, sehr gerne uns Hinweise schicken. Ich freue mich, wenn wir da unser Gäste-Portfolio erweitern und auch in dieser Hinsicht inhaltlich wachsen. Dann haben wir den Nationalteamsfeed, habe ich gerade schon angesprochen. Der ist neu gestartet. Da war es natürlich perfekt, denn es ging los mit der WM-Vorschau auf die FrauenwM, mit der doppelteiligen, zweiteiligen WM-Vorschau. Wer hätte das ahnen können, dass das zwei Teile werden können?
Da fällt mir tatsächlich auch gerade einer sich Unsinn erzählt hat, weil der Start war ja natürlich nicht zur neuen Saison, sondern der Start war ja zur Weltmeisterschaft. Das hat ja tatsächlich dieses ganze Website-Relaunchen-Thema noch ein bisschen brisanter gemacht, weil ich glaube, die WM-Vorschau war am 14., 15. Wir hatten am 7. Juli unseren Umzugstermin. Also das war nämlich tatsächlich der Grund, warum das ein bisschen sehr knackig war, weil wir da die letzten Arbeiten quasi mitten in den Umzug legen mussten. Aber ja, hat natürlich ideal gepasst, weil so ein Event, so eine Weltmeisterschaft zu haben zum Start des neuen Feeds war natürlich ein Traum und war wahrscheinlich mit dafür verantwortlich, warum der Nationalmannschaftsfeed zu gut angelaufen ist.
Definitiv. Und ich musste mir immer sehr auf die Zunge beißen, wenn mir irgendwelche Leute Feedback zum Royale geschrieben haben mit den Worten, jetzt ruhe dich aber mal aus und ich halt gleichzeitig im Backend die ganzen neuen Folgen zu geordnet geguckt, ob die Feeds passen, plus mich vorbereitet auf die ganzen Nationalteams. Es war eigentlich genauso stressig wie der Royale, muss man sagen, aber niemand will das hören von jemandem, dem man gerade gute Erholung wünscht, dass derjenige zurückschreibt, nee, ist gerade ganz schlimm. Also was hätte es uns alle weitergebracht?
Stimmt.
Aber umso schöner das geklappt hat und man muss auch sagen, wir werden nochmal gesondert über Annika und WM und so weiter sprechen, aber an der Stelle nochmal riesen Dank an Annika und Nina, dass sie bei dieser Vorschau mitgemacht haben. Das war alles andere als selbstverständlich und diese Vorschau hat auch am allerbesten funktioniert von allen WM-Sendungen, hat sehr, sehr viele Downloads bekommen. Ich habe inzwischen von auch ganz vielen Journalistinnen gehört, dass sie es auf dem Flug nach Australien gehört haben. Die fanden dann auch die Länge auf einmal alle ganz okay. Sonst mottet es gerade immer die Journalisten.
Den war es wahrscheinlich eher zu kurz. 18 Stunden Flug.
Flugzeit anpassen können. Also deswegen wird natürlich dann die EM-Vorschau auf die EM in der Schweiz bei den Frauen, die wird natürlich ganz kurz, weil in die Schweiz fährt man nicht so lange. Also der Nationalteam-Speed ist gut angekommen. Man sieht hier, dass die Vorschau und die Rückblickformate am besten funktionieren. Das war aber schon immer so. Wir sind hier aber auf einem sehr guten Niveau schon eingestiegen. Die täglichen WM-Sendungen haben auch sehr gut funktioniert, auch zum Beispiel deutlich besser als die Bundesliga der Frauen aktuell noch. Das heißt, noch ein größeres Publikum hat sich dafür interessiert. Deutlich zu sehen war auch, es gibt ein gesondertes Interesse am deutschen Team. Immer an den Spieltagen mit deutschen Spielen hatten wir noch deutlich höhere Downloads und rein theoretisch müssten wir jetzt die allergrößten Deutschland-Fans sein, denn wie eigentlich zu erwarten ist, mit Fortschreiten im Turnier wurden die Downloads immer höher und hätte Deutschland die K.o.-Runde erreicht, wäre es noch weiter hochgegangen. Das haben wir bei der EM schon gesehen. Aber allein deshalb werden wir jetzt nicht unsere inhaltliche Kritik über Bord werfen. Ich wollte es euch nur mitteilen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Es ist definitiv so, je erfolgreicher ein Team, desto mehr steigen die Downloads oder je mehr passiert. Denn wir hatten danach ja dann auch die neuen Nationalteamsendungen sowohl zu Frauen als auch zu Männern. Ich habe mich lange drumherum gewunden, über Länderspiele im regulären Jahr außerhalb von Turnieren zu sprechen. Das hatte ganz verschiedene Gründe. Unter anderem waren das meine letzten freien Wochenenden oder halb frei. So richtig frei waren sie eigentlich nie. Das haben wir jetzt geändert und damit bin ich aber auch sehr zufrieden. Denn sowohl bei den Frauen, wo ja auch wirklich viel los war mit Martina Vosteklenburg und so weiter und so fort, als auch bei den Männern sehen wir, es kommt sehr gut an, es interessiert euch auch dieser Entscheidung zu sagen, wir machen das immer nach den zwei Länderspielen. Also jetzt nicht nach jedem Spiel eine schnelle Folge, sondern wir machen eine ausgeruhte Folge, wo man vielleicht auch nicht mehr so im Detail in die Spiele reingucken muss, sondern eher das größere Ganze bespricht. Das kommt sehr gut an und ich habe das Gefühl, ich weiß nicht wie dir das geht, das baut uns auch eine wunderschöne Rampe zu kommenden Turnieren, unter anderem ja zur Männer-EM.
Ja absolut, ich glaube da war die Defeat-Umstellung ein großer Schritt und ich erinnere ja noch die ganzen Diskussionen der letzten Jahre immer, wenn dann doch mal was war, wo man gesagt hat, okay, da müssen wir jetzt eine Sendung zumachen, ja wo passt sie jetzt rein? Ich mache einen Kurzpass, ah ne, aber die Sendung wird anderthalb Stunden lang, ist es dann noch ein Kurzpass? Also wir haben da ja schon mittlerweile auch bei der Defeat-Umstellung ausführlich darüber gesprochen, auch öffentlich, aber die alte Defeat-Struktur hat uns so ein bisschen gebunden in einerseits, eigentlich nie inhaltlich, aber immer auf die Länge der Sendung und auf den Charakter. Es ist jetzt ein Interview, es ist irgendwie wirklich ein monothematisches, längeres Gespräch, es ist dann ein Tribünengespräch, aber eigentlich ist es inhaltlich dann zu dünn und so. Jetzt haben wir eine klare Aufteilung und jetzt haben die Nationalmannschaftsthemen einen eigenen Feed und das finde ich super, also die Möglichkeit da jetzt einfach wie du sagst, nicht unbedingt zu jedem Spiel einzeln und detailliert auf das Spiel eingehen, aber so eine Art Nationalmannschafts-Update immer zu machen, finde ich eine klasse Variante und ich glaube auch, dass uns das eine sehr gute Rampe baut für die Turniere und man da eben auch gut im Vorfeld so ein bisschen darauf hinarbeiten kann und nicht unbedingt nur die eine Vorschau hat und dann das Turnier.
Es ist fast ein bisschen schade, dass so wenige Länderspiele stattfinden, also zu den Männern wäre die reguläre Sendung ja irgendwann im März, wenn die ihre zwei Länderspiele noch haben, die letzten vor der EM. Bei den Frauen geht es Ende Februar bzw. Anfang März dann weiter. Mal gucken, aber da will ich jetzt lieber auch nichts versprechen. Ja und gleichzeitig weiß ich aber, was wir bringen bis dahin. Also wir bringen von jetzt von dieser Sendung bis zur EM-Vorschau ohne den Rasen von Kroyal 68 Sendungen, die zumindest geplant sind aktuell. Deswegen bin ich sehr sehr zurückhaltend, jetzt hier irgendwie anzukündigen, vielleicht mache ich mal noch so eine Sendung zwischendurch, denn ich weiß nicht wann.
Aus dem Rasenfunk Medienhochhaus.
Es ist wirklich sehr sehr extremen. Den Tribüngespräch Fied, der hat am wenigsten Veränderungen erfahren, was neue Sendungen angeht. Interessant aber, dass es jetzt viel einfacher ist und dass es auch gut ankam, manche ältere Sendungen da reinzupacken, die halt bisher im Kurzpass versaut ist, um es mal so deutlich zu sagen. Der Tribüngespräch Fied hat auch so ein bisschen seine Charakteristik geändert, aber er funktioniert weiter sehr gut. Wir haben sogar auf dem Papier zwölf Sendungen gemacht. Du weißt noch, das war mal unser altes Ziel, ein Tribüngespräch pro Monat. Gehört allerdings jetzt auch mit dazu, dass da so zwei drei Sendungen mit dabei waren. Wir schicken Annika zu WM oder wir erkündigen erstmal an, dass wir die Fieds umstellen, die keine klassischen Tribüngespräche waren. Aber dennoch haben wir echt einiges hinbekommen und was mich sehr gefreut hat, für dich jetzt keine Neuigkeit, aber ich möchte es nochmal an die Hörerinnen und Hörer weitergeben, das Tribüngespräch in das mit Abstand die meiste Arbeit geflossen ist. Da habe ich ja mehrere Monate dran gesessen. Das zur Zukunft des Fußballs hat auch die meisten Downloads bekommen. Es könnte meiner Ansicht nach noch mehr sein. Wir sind da auf einem Niveau, da kommt man also mit Spieler-Interviews leichter hin, sage ich jetzt mal, und dann wird man übertroffen. Aber ich war dann doch sehr froh, dass der Aufwand es wert war, ja auch der finanzielle Aufwand. Da haben wir ja für Musik und so weiter gezahlt und mehrere Gäste gehabt. Ansonsten kamen die Investorentribüngespräche sehr gut an und ohne jetzt ins Detail zu gehen, glaube ich, können wir sagen, wir sind sehr zufrieden damit, wie sich das Format weiter nimmt.
Absolut, absolut. Ich glaube auch, das ist schon relativ früh in unseren Gedanken, das wichtigste Format für den Rasenfunk so ein bisschen. Auch wenn in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung vielleicht eher ein bisschen underdog, weil halt natürlich die Regelmäßigkeit der damaligen Schlusskonferenz, jetzigen Bundesliga-Analyse da ein bisschen mehr sichtbar ist und ein bisschen mehr nach vorne steht. Aber auf das Tribüngengespräch setzen wir große Dinge auch in Zukunft und da sind wir schon sehr zufrieden.
Absolut und da wird auch wieder einiges kommen, ohne dass ich da jetzt konkreter werden möchte aus diversen Gründen. Und dann haben wir als letztes noch die Ligatour, wo wir uns ja letztlich dazu entschieden haben, ein Sammelgefäß noch zu lassen. Also nicht alles auszudifferenzieren, alles andere ist so ein bisschen thematisch geworden. Tribüngespräch ist dann ein Sammelgefäß und Ligatour bleibt weiter ein Sammelgefäß, denn alles, was quasi nicht Bundesliga ist, also erste Bundesliga, Männer oder Frauen, das landet dort. Und damit haben wir da vor allem zwei Hauptformate, nämlich zum einen der Blick auf die europäischen Top-Ligen, exklusive Liga, muss man leider sagen in der Hinrunde. Ich grüße alle Liga-Experten, aber ich weiß, ihr hattet es. Es hat sich einfach nicht, es ist sich nicht ausgegangen. Wir werden das hoffentlich in der Rückrunde ein bisschen besser hinbekommen. Und die zweite Bundesliga der Männer wird hier viel besprochen. Wir hatten allerdings auch eins, eine andere Sendung. Das hat mir auch wieder gezeigt, warum es gut war, dieses Sammelgefäß zu behalten. Weil hätten wir jetzt gesagt, wir machen einen Zweitliga-Feed und wir machen ein Ligatour-Europa-Feed. Wo hätte ich denn dann genau über Ajax gesprochen oder über die Copa Libertadores, die dann eben auch nicht mehr Europa ist. Es gibt zwar trotzdem noch manchmal, wir haben da schon drüber gesprochen, dass die Zweitliga-Sendungen eigentlich mehr HörerInnen finden müssten, nachdem, wie wir einfach sehen, wie andere Inhalte funktionieren und wie eben die Podcastlandschaft funktioniert. Wir haben das Gefühl, dass auch da weder noch, da fehlt vielleicht ein Werbeeffekt, vielleicht ist die Regelmäßigkeit auch nicht gut genug, vielleicht auch nicht die Vorhersehbarkeit, welche Vereine da drankommen. Also nehmt auch das gerne noch mal als Anlass, vielleicht andere Menschen auf, eben solche Sendungen hinzuweisen, wenn ihr Verein vorkommt. Also da gibt es schon noch Optimierungsbedarf und wir haben da auch schon auch noch mal inhaltliche Gedanken geführt. Wer weiß, ob sich der Ligatour-Feed könnte sich noch mal verändern. Aber insgesamt war die Trennung gut. Die Ligatur ist jetzt klarer erkennbar, um was es geht und die Downloads sind okay. Sie könnten allerdings höher sein, so ehrlich muss man glaube ich schon sein, gemessen am Aufwand vor allem.
Ja, definitiv. Und ich meine, was den Feed angeht, hat natürlich so ein Sammelbecken, wie du es nennst, immer den Nachteil, dass da eben andere Dinge mit drin sind, die einen eben vielleicht selber nicht so interessieren. Wir haben aber immer noch auch die Plattform YouTube, da werden wir vielleicht auch noch ein Wort drüber verlieren, die immer wichtiger wird. Ich glaube, für Podcasts generell, wenn ich das so in meinem Interessenbereich andernorts beurteile, aber auch für den Rasenfunk. Ich bin sehr froh, dass wir das mit der zweiten Liga so ein bisschen etabliert haben jetzt, weil das war ja doch auch ein regelmäßiges Feedback der letzten Jahre, dass den Leuten das gefehlt hat. Wenn ihr jetzt zuhört und Fans von einem Zweitliga-Verein seid und die Zweitliga-Ligatur hoffentlich regelmäßig hört, dann gebt uns doch vielleicht im Forum auch mal Feedback dazu, wie ihr es seht. Habt ihr eine Meinung dazu, was zum Beispiel die Verteilung der Vereine angeht? Das, was Max gerade angesprochen hat, die Zuverlässigkeit der Inhalte und das der zeitlichen Veröffentlichung.
Vor allem eine Frage würde mich konkret interessieren, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Die Aufteilung, die sich jetzt so ein bisschen ergeben hat, also am Anfang ganz grob über den Spieltag sprechen und dann drei Vereine jeweils so rund 20 Minuten und dann landen wir bei einer Stunde 15. Ist das für euch so, wie ihr es gerne hättet? Ist das die Art von Überblick, die ihr haben wollt? Oder würdet ihr ein Modell, ohne dass ich sagen könnte, dass wir das jetzt umgesetzt bekämen, aber ein Modell, wie wir es in der ersten Liga haben, ein Verein für eine Stunde, würdet ihr das besser finden? Allerdings möchte ich da gleich die Klammer drum machen. Ob wir da alle 18 Vereine schaffen, das kann ich nicht garantieren, weil das wäre, das würde natürlich komplett alles sprengen. Deswegen sind wir ja bei drei Vereinen gelandet und auch, weil ich finde, also die Zweitligatur, die ist so ein Hybrid zwischen schon aktuell auf den Spieltag blicken und auch auf die aktuelle Situation, aber auch über das größere Ganze zu sprechen. Und ich glaube, dass gerade bei Teams, auf die man sonst nicht so oft blickt, sogar so Schwerpunktthemen dann tendenziell noch länger werden würden. Und das ist dann sowohl für den Moderator eine Herausforderung als auch für diejenigen, die es hören. Aber das würde mich interessieren. Ist dieser Mix, den wir gerade haben, ist er für euch genau richtig oder sagt er, naja, wenn ich es mir raussuchen könnte, dann hätte ich gerne eher den Deep Dive, so ähnlich, wie wir ihn in der ersten Liga bekommen. Und wir wollen einfach erstmal die Rückmeldung einsammeln und dann müssten wir gucken, ob man da überhaupt was verändern kann. Aber das ist eine Frage, die ich mir ehrlich gesagt schon oft gestellt habe. Also sind wir gespannt, wie da eure Rückmeldung ist. Frank, dann lass uns doch jetzt noch über Video sprechen und über YouTube, weil jetzt hast du es gerade schon so schön eingeführt. Wie findest du es denn, dass wir uns jetzt gerade sehen?
Absolut klasse. Also natürlich, wenn wir im Gespräch uns sehen, hat einen großen Vorteil, finde ich. Und haben wir ja eigentlich auch erst kurz bevor wir tatsächlich die Videoveröffentlichung eingeführt haben, gestartet. Das war, um wieder das zeitlich einzuordnen, unser Gespräch im Mai zu den neuen Feeds. Da gab es gerade die ersten öffentlichen Sendungen mit Video. Also es ist ein bisschen älter jetzt als die neuen Feeds, die Tatsache, dass es uns im Video gibt. Und ich finde es super. Man sieht es an den YouTube Zahlen, dass das natürlich ganz viel ausmacht, wenn da jetzt plötzlich Video ist. Und ich glaube, es gibt einfach den Zuschauern, sicherlich viele davon, ehemalige Zuhörer, die sich vielleicht vorher nicht zu YouTube bewegt haben, wo es nur das Audio gab, jetzt aber vielleicht auch mal bei YouTube reingucken, um eben die Gesichter dazu zu sehen. Ich finde es klasse. Ich höre selber mittlerweile einige Podcasts über Video, auch wenn ich da nicht die ganze Zeit hinschaue. Aber es ist definitiv ein tolles Add-on, finde ich. Und die Statistiken geben es ja schon her, dass es sich gelohnt hat, würde ich sagen. Der Aufwand ist natürlich nicht ohne.
Ja, also genau. Ich möchte da quasi, man muss da quasi einmal inhaltlich drüber sprechen, was verändert es mit dem auch Audio-Produkt. Und dann, glaube ich, kann man über Statistik sprechen. Weil das ist mir ganz wichtig, das zu betonen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Wir haben das nicht nur gemacht, um auf YouTube zu wachsen. Wir müssen zwar auf YouTube wachsen, denn wir wachsen als Podcast. Wenn ihr dieses Format jetzt schon regelmäßig hört, haben wir schon öfter gesagt. Genau. Also wir müssen noch wachsen, wenn wir eben mehr covern wollen, wenn wir vielleicht noch größer werden wollen, auch inhaltlich eben größer werden wollen. Und da ist YouTube aktuell der einzige Kanal, auf dem wir wachsen. Aber es ging eben nicht nur bei der Überlegung darum, sondern es ging auch darum, was macht es mit dem Inhalt der Sendung und quasi auch dem, was ihr im Audio hört, verbessert ist das. Und dazu muss man sagen, wir haben schon ganz, ganz früh Videoversuche gestartet. Ursprünglich hätte ja der Rasenfunk ein Live-Video-Format sein sollen.
Das wissen jetzt nur die ältesten Hörerinnen und Hörer.
Aber damals war einfach die Technik noch nicht weit genug. Vor allem das Internet war noch zu schlecht. Damit haben wir jetzt immer noch Probleme, aber nicht mal so schlimm. Und es gibt jetzt eben technische Lösungen, die besser sind. Wir nehmen mit Zencaster auf und das funktioniert okay. Man hat manchmal Videoausfälle, aber das Audio kommt immer sauber an. Und ich habe die Möglichkeit, mitzugegeben einem höheren Aufwand als früher, dann die lokalen Audiospuren und die Videospielen übereinander zu legen und alles gemeinsam zu schneiden. Das dauert alles länger, aber seitdem wir da auch für neue Technik gesorgt haben, geht es. Und ihr merkt das nicht. Was man aber dem Audioprodukt auch anmerkt, meiner Meinung nach, ist, dass es ein riesiger Vorteil ist, dass sich die Gäste nun gegenseitig sehen. Bisher haben wir eine Lösung gehabt im Rasenfunk für die ersten neuneinhalb Jahre, in der man auf ein Browserfenster geguckt hat und da sah man den Ausschlag, wenn jemand anderes gesprochen hat, aber ansonsten sah man nichts. Und gerade für Neulinge war das, glaube ich, undankbar. Denn der Rasenfunk zeichnet sich dadurch aus, dass ein Wortbeitrag nicht 30 Sekunden dauert, sondern zwei Minuten. Der Rasenfunk kennzeichnet sich dadurch, dass jemand vier Minuten monologisiert und zwischendurch aber auch mal zwei schlechte Gags macht. Das bin dann ich in dem Fall. Und das ist ein riesiger Unterschied, wenn man als Gast und auch als Moderator, muss ich sagen, wenn man sieht, die anderen, sie hören zu, sie nicken, sie grinsen vielleicht bei einem Witz, obwohl sie sich nicht entmuted haben. Eva, die lacht sogar immer, hat sich leider nicht entmuted. Das ist schade. Ich würde sehen, wie lustig Eva manche Sachen findet. Ich sage, man hört das leider manchmal nicht. Aber das ist tatsächlich ein riesiger Zugewinn, der für eine ganz andere Grundstimmung in den Podcast sorgt. Und manchmal haben wir jetzt zwar dann das Problem, dass etwas im Video passiert, was ich dann als Moderator sagen muss. Das sind dann so Einschübungen, die ich mache. Ich sehe ihr nickt oder ich sehe ihr seht das ein bisschen anders. Du guckst ein bisschen skeptisch. Das muss ich jetzt machen. Das musste ich früher nicht machen. Aber es ist viel angenehmer für die Gäste, auch für diejenigen, die skeptisch waren. Weil nicht jeder möchte gesehen werden, wenn er drei Stunden über die Bundesliga spricht. Aber das hat das ganze Produkt meiner Meinung nach besser gemacht. Ich habe das auch als Rückmeldung von den Gästen bekommen. Und allein deshalb hätte es sich gelohnt, selbst wenn wir jetzt feststellen würden, YouTube wäre kein Faktor für uns gewesen.
Übrigens bin ich ein bisschen positiv überrascht davon, wie viele Gäste fein damit sind. Ich dachte eher, dass es mehr Zurückhaltung gibt. Und ich bin sehr überrascht davon und finde es toll, wie viele da einfach mitmachen. Auch wenn sie vielleicht wissen, jetzt die eigene Kamera ist nicht so toll oder ich habe eigentlich kein tolles Licht oder was auch immer. Am Ende nicht schlimm, wäre natürlich immer schöner. Nicht nur beim Ton, sondern auch beim Bild, wenn es am Ende cool aussieht und so.
Ja, das finde ich auch. Und dazu muss man immer noch sagen, aktuell ist es immer noch Nebenprodukt. Also im Zweifel werde ich mich immer für die stabile Audio-Variante entscheiden. Das heißt, die YouTube-Zuseherinnen da draußen, die wissen es ja auch schon, dann gibt es auch manchmal eben kein Video oder es hat technisch irgendwas nicht geklappt. Der Upload der Videodateien ist tatsächlich das Nadelöhr, durch das wir durch müssen und dass diesen Test besteht der Internetstandort Deutschland nicht an jedem Ort, so muss man sagen. Aber um dann eben auf YouTube zu kommen, da hat sich das voll ausgezahlt. Wir haben ohne jetzt schon die letzte Stufe gezündet zu haben da einen deutlichen Zugewinn an AbonnentInnen. Also wir hatten 6000 als wir und zwar konstant über zwei Jahre hatten wir glaube ich 6000 AbonnentInnen bei YouTube bis wir mit Video begonnen haben. Jetzt sind wir bei 8000, das heißt wir haben 2000 dazugewonnen im Zeitraum zwischen April bis eben Dezember des letzten Jahres und das obwohl unsere Videos bei YouTube nicht monetarisiert sind, auch nicht auf der geringsten Stufe und das sehr schlecht für den Algorithmus ist. Also wir würden noch mehr Leute erreichen, wenn wir die Monetarisierung aktivieren würden, dann würden allerdings die Pre-Roll Ads, die man kennt und ich glaube auch Midway würden auch welche laufen, weil unsere Sendungen so lang sind. Das würde es geben. Wir haben es aus verschiedenen Gründen. Den größten könnt ihr euch denken, nämlich wir finden Werbung doof und wollen den Rasenfunk werbefrei halten, haben uns da noch dagegen entschieden. Ob das immer so bleibt, können wir aber nicht sagen, weil man das schon merkt und das ja auch bei anderen Formaten so ist, die werbefrei gehalten werden. Junge naiv ist davon sicher eins der bekanntesten. Die haben auch die Pre-Roll Ads aktiviert, weil sie eben wissen, es wirkt sich sehr positiv auf den Algorithmus aus, denn YouTube möchte, wer hätte es gedacht, Geld verdienen.
Wenn ihr irgendwann Werbung bei den Rasenfunk Videos seht, dann könnt ihr euch aber sicher sein, wir tun es nicht um Geld zu verdienen, weil in den Größenordnungen, in denen wir uns bewegen, da wird es schwer einen Kaffee für jeden im Monat rauszuholen. Insofern seid euch sicher, das ist dann ein Grund, um die Sichtbarkeit zu verbessern und nicht um wirklich Geld damit zu verdienen.
Das ist ja einer der größten Gründe dagegen, dass das, was wir da einnehmen, locker durch den Buchhaltungsaufwand mehr als weggefressen wird. Aber wir sind sehr zufrieden und wir haben da ja auch ein bisschen was verändert. Also die Art und Weise, wie die Videos präsentiert werden, ist jetzt schon ein bisschen anders. Da gibt es sicherlich auch noch Luft nach oben. Ich probiere da auch noch ein bisschen was rum. Gleichzeitig muss man aber auch so ehrlich sein, das Hauptprodukt muss audio bleiben und wegen der langen Bearbeitungszeit, die man bräuchte, um ein Video jetzt richtig professionell zu machen, wird es das wahrscheinlich auch auf dem Rasenfunk-Kanal sehr lange nicht geben, weil wir ja auch einen zeitlichen Druck haben. Also die Analysesendung, sowohl das Video als auch das Audio, soll möglichst schnell nach dem Spieltag online gehen. Das können wir jetzt nicht noch irgendeinem Cutter schicken, der dann da irgendwelche Schnitte reinmacht. Das muss ich machen und dann ist das sehr hands-on und sehr rough. Aber, und das möchte ich jetzt auch mal ausschließlich, ausdrücklich betonen, weil ich schon öfter kritische Dinge auch gesagt habe über die YouTube-Community. Ich finde, die entwickelt sich ganz, ganz fantastisch und das macht mir wirklich große Freude und zwar aus mehreren Gründen. Zum einen ist es so, dass wir viel mehr Feedback bekommen über YouTube als übers Forum. Looking at you, Audio-only-Hörer. Ihr müsst mal ein bisschen mehr Feedback dalassen.
Das heißt, das mit dem Looking at you klappt aber in dem Fall nicht.
Sehr, sehr schöner, freuter Versprecher. Aber wenn ich wissen möchte, wie die Sendung ankommt, ob wir vielleicht einen groben Fehler drin hatten, den ich übersehen habe und so weiter. Und das ist immer so in den ersten Stunden nach Veröffentlichung, da ist man da immer so ein bisschen nervös, ehrlicherweise. Dann gucke ich auf YouTube, denn bei YouTube bekommen wir sehr, sehr schnell Feedback, bis im Forum mal was einläuft. Da dauert es meistens. Und das finde ich sehr positiv. Ich mag das, dass ich bei YouTube einen direkten Feedback-Kanal habe. Gleichzeitig finde ich, dass der Ton außerordentlich gut ist inzwischen. Es gibt natürlich immer mal wieder die Ausreißer, die ganz offensichtlich von außen reinkommen in den YouTube-Kanal und dann halt da so kommentieren, wie sie sonst vielleicht auch bei YouTube kommentieren. Aber es gab jetzt auch schon mehrfach den Fall. Und das ist immer das Zeichen, dass etwas sehr, sehr Gutes im Entstehen ist, dass die Community selber das eingefangen hat. Ich habe es dann zwei Stunden später erst gesehen, da hat schon jemand drunter kommentiert, ey, so brauchst du hier nicht ankommen. In diesem Ton machen wir das nicht. Oder sag doch mal überhaupt, was dein Kritikpunkt ist. Das ist eigentlich so das Hauptsächliche, dass irgendjemand drunter schreibt, was für eine Scheiße. Und man denkt sich so, ja, herzlichen Dank, was soll ich denn jetzt hiermit anfangen? Und das finde ich ganz, ganz herausragend. Liebe YouTube-Zuseherinnen und Zuseher. Und natürlich gibt es manche Grundsatzdiskussionen. Allein, dass ich hier schon wieder gendert habe, wird manche triggern. Es gibt auch manche, die nicht damit aufhören können, sich immer wieder und wieder zu beschweren. Es fehlt nur der Zusatz. Das hatten wir früher oft. Weißt du noch, die Mails, die wir bekommen haben, ich höre euch nie wieder. Und zwei Wochen gab es dann wieder eine Mail, ihr mit eurem scheiß gendern, ich höre euch nie wieder.
Ich kann mich an den einen oder anderen Namen erinnern, der das über Jahre so gezogen hat.
Da gab es sogar neulich mal wieder eine E-Mail. Also er hört uns immer noch. Derjenige ganz so schlimm scheint es mit dem gendern dann noch nicht zu sein. Also das passiert immer wieder. Aber ich schätze das wirklich sehr und das macht große Freude. Und, und das wollte ich auch noch kurz anfügen, dann darfst du auch endlich mal wieder was sagen. Ich bekomme das auch von Gästen zurückgespiegelt. Denn gerade diese Entscheidung, sich mit dem eigenen Gesicht und dem eigenen Wohnzimmer ins Internet zu stellen, das macht es ja noch mal so erstaunlich, was du vorhin schon hervorgehoben hast, dass das bisher eigentlich fast alle Gäste bereit waren mitzumachen und zu sagen, ja okay, klar machen wir das per Video und du darfst es auch veröffentlichen. Und das ist, glaube ich, keine leichte Entscheidung. Zumindest mir wäre diese Entscheidung nicht leicht gefallen. Ich musste mich da selber dran gewöhnen. Und dann zu wissen, dass wir mit ganz, ganz wenigen Ausnahmen niemand in den Kommentaren haben, der über Aussehenssprüche macht, der über Wohneinrichtungen Sprüche macht oder über die Art und Weise einfach, wie man sich von der Kamera gibt. Das ist eine große Wohltat, das kommt sehr gut auch bei den Gästen an. Und gleichzeitig, wenn jemand zum Aussehen und so weiter einen Kommentar macht, ich lösche sogar die Positiven. Denn darum soll es bei den YouTube Videos nicht gehen. Ich möchte einfach diesen Lookism nicht, egal ob ihr sagt, ich finde deinen Hoodie toll oder ich finde dein Gesicht ganz, ganz fürchterlich. Beides, lasst es einfach, kommentiert gerne inhaltlich, alles andere nehme ich raus. Aber das waren irgendwie drei Kommentare oder so im letzten halben Jahr. Also es kommt wirklich sehr selten vor und das finde ich toll.
Ja, definitiv. Absolut klasse, weil man sich ja eben, wie du es eben schon angedeutet hast, ein Stück weit verletzlich macht, wenn man sich im Bild zeigt, egal ob es jetzt eben ein Mann selbst ist oder der Raum, in dem man sich befindet, die Art, wie man sich kleidet. Und dass das im Rahmen bleibt und dass das große Ausnahmen sind, die darauf eingehen, finde ich super, super klasse. Was ich zu den Kommentaren noch sagen wollte, da macht sich natürlich ein Vorteil einer Plattform. Ich meine, wir haben ja oft über Plattformen diskutiert, über die Vor- und Nachteile. Und da hat natürlich YouTube seinen großen Vorteil, dadurch dass der Kommentarschlitz drunter ist. Man in der Regel, wenn man YouTube Videos regelmäßig guckt, ohnehin dort angemeldet und registriert ist und einfach kommentieren kann, wohingegen das halt in einem Podcatcher immer noch nicht so funktioniert, macht sich da natürlich deutlich dadurch, dass, wie du erwähnt hast, das Feedback viel schneller da ist nach der Sendung. Und das ist natürlich ein tolles Instrument, einfach auch für uns schnelles Feedback zu bekommen. Aber trotzdem, Audiohörer, mitmachen.rasenfunk.de ist der Ort, an dem ihr euch registrieren könnt und uns Feedback geben und teilnehmen an der Community. Vor allem, wir haben es jetzt schon öfter gesagt, wir versuchen auch unsere Hörerinnen und Hörer, so gut es geht, mit einzubinden, auch in Entscheidungen, strategische Entscheidungen so ein bisschen. Wo sie als mit dem Rasenfunk hingehen und damit machen, rasenfunk.de eben Forum, könnt ihr euch da beteiligen und uns helfen.
Und das wird auch so bleiben, das muss man so deutlich sagen. Das Forum wird immer ein besonderer Ort bleiben, an dem ihr vielleicht auch mal Einblicke bekommt, an dem ihr auf jeden Fall, also jeder Kommentar wird gelesen. Ich gucke immer erst ins Forum und dann auf alle anderen Plattformen, einfach weil das unsere Plattform ist. Weil wir da die Hoheit über die Kommentare haben, weil wir wissen, hier wird sich technisch nichts zu unseren Ungunsten verändern. Und das ist ganz wichtig für den Rasenfunk, so wie für alle anderen Publisher da draußen ja auch. Und wir haben das ja auch schon an vielen Beispielen gesehen, warum das eine richtige Entscheidung ist. Zum Beispiel an der Art und Weise, wie sich Slack verändert hat, das hatten wir vorher intern mal im Einsatz. Hätten wir da etwas ähnliches gestartet, wie es jetzt bei Discord gibt, von Fans betrieben zum Rasenfunk, deswegen machen wir das nicht offiziell vom Rasenfunk. Hätten wir ein riesen Problem gehabt.
Aber guter Punkt. Ich wollte es gerade noch sagen, lass uns Discord an der Stelle noch erwähnen. Für diejenigen, die bei Discord sind, es gibt auch bei Discord einen inoffiziellen Rasenfunk-Server. Max hat es eben angedeutet. Der Grund, warum er inoffiziell ist, ist eben genau der. Wir haben bei Discord die Daten nicht in der Hand. Wir haben das Problem, wenn Discord morgen irgendeine blöde Entscheidung fällt, ähnlich wie bei Slack, dann ist die ganze History weg und...
Oder von einem Antisemiten gekauft wird wie Twitter. Also deswegen schaut natürlich auch an die Discord-Community. Lesen wir auch gerne mit. Manchmal habt ihr noch das Problem, liebe Discordies da draußen, ich nenne euch jetzt einfach mal so, dass ihr vergesst, dass die inhaltlich sehr, sehr guten Diskussionen manchmal auch ins Forum rüber kopiert werden könnten, damit da dann weiter diskutiert wird. Bei Discord ist es eher so, die hören dann schnell auf, weil dann kommt jemand anderes und sagt, habt ihr das und das gesehen? Ist ja auch der Charakter von Discord. Genau. Aber habt das manchmal noch im Hintergrund, ich hab, ich lese nicht immer alles nach, ich lese immer den Rasenfunk-Channel, habe ich euch ja auch schon geschrieben, wenn ihr dort was schreibt, das sehe ich immer alles andere, je nach Lust und Laune. Aber ich gebe es zu auch manchmal schon live für ein Spiel. Manchmal habe ich mir gedacht, jetzt bin ich gespannt, was sie drüben bei Discord schreiben. Und dann habe ich gesehen, ah, sie kotzen genauso ab, wie ich mich gerade fühle. Sehr, sehr gut. Also ich bin dann manchmal auch stiller Mitleser. Schön, dass wir diesen Schlenker noch zu Discord gemacht haben. Einen großen Schlenker, den wir gemacht haben in diesem oder im letzten Jahr, war der zur Frauen-WM in Australien, bei der dann doch mehr deutsche Journalistinnen vor Ort waren, als wir antizipiert hatten. Da muss man, glaube ich, einigen Medien Komplimente aussprechen. Aber dennoch haben wir es geschafft, Frank. Wir haben Annika Becker dort hingeschickt. Sie war unsere persönliche WM-Referentin. Sie kam in ganz, ganz vielen Aufnahmen von dort, meistens aus dem Stadion zugeschaltet vor. Sie hat Pressekonferenzen für uns besucht, hatte eine sehr arbeitsame, aber hoffentlich auch positive Zeit für Sie. Ich will jetzt nicht für Annika sprechen. Welche Bilanz würdest du denn ziehen mit Blick auf dieses WM-Abenteuer?
Eine absolute positive. Ich glaube, das war ein Riesenschritt für uns. Ich kann mich übrigens erinnern, wo wir zum ersten Mal darüber gesprochen haben. Das war nämlich vor dem Notartermin zur GmbH-Gründung.
Nach dem Notartermin, aber auf dem Parkplatz.
Aber auf dem Parkplatz, genau. Das waren zwei große Schritte an einem Tag, quasi. So ein bisschen. Da haben wir uns so grundsätzlich darüber verständigt, dass wir das verfolgen wollen und dass wir das machen wollen. Unterm Strich, glaube ich, super positiv, kann man da nur sagen, um es zusammenzufassen. Im Detail müssen wir da sicherlich über Einzelheiten sprechen, wie man das vielleicht beim nächsten Mal anders machen kann. Aber ansonsten würde ich sagen, war das ein klasse Event für uns auch und eine Bestätigung, dass wir auch mit der Community, die das ja finanziert hat, so etwas aufziehen können und so einen großen Schritt wagen können, der sicherlich erstmal für uns sehr ungewöhnlich war und wahrscheinlich auch für die meisten unter euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, dass der Rasenfunk jetzt so einen Schritt geht, unser so viel Geld in die Hand nimmt und Annika für uns den großen Aufwand betreibt, fand ich echt klasse und hat am Ende, glaube ich, gut funktioniert, kann man sagen.
Genauso, weil die Frage sicherlich von euch gekommen wäre, wir haben es finanziert bekommen. Die Kosten waren ungefähr so, wie wir es angekündigt haben. Ich glaube, wir haben 10.000 genannt. Es waren dann ein bisschen mehr, aber nicht so arg drüber und wir sollten das finanziert bekommen haben, unter anderem wegen eines sehr, sehr großzügigen Spenders, dem wir nochmal ganz herzlich danken wollen an dieser Stelle. Wir wussten immer nicht so ganz, ist das jetzt gewollt, dass hier nochmal irgendwie öffentlich was gesagt wird oder nicht. Es wirkte eher nicht so, aber wir haben es gesehen, vielen, vielen herzlichen Dank. Eine kleine Klammer, finde ich, muss man aber um diese Erfolgsgeschichte schon machen oder einen Appendix anfügen, nämlich das, was wir erhofft hatten, nämlich dass wir dadurch auch neue dauerhafte Spender bekommen. Wir haben ja nicht, deswegen haben wir das ja nicht zweckgebunden gemacht, haben nicht gesagt, schick uns jetzt 10 Euro für Annika, die wir dann zur WM schicken, sondern überleg doch, ob du jetzt Rasenfunk-Supporterin werden möchtest, damit wir auch Annika zur WM schicken und eben in nächsten Schritten noch weitere Dinge tun. Das scheint nicht so ganz geklappt zu haben. Es waren eher die bestehenden UnterstützerInnen, die ihre Unterstützung erhöht haben oder nochmal einmalig etwas gezahlt haben. Es ist für uns natürlich schwierig, das jetzt irgendwie rauszufiltern, aber es war jetzt nicht zu erkennen, dass da jetzt hunderte neue UnterstützerInnen dazu gekommen wären. Das war ein bisschen schade, ohne dass ich mich darüber irgendwie beschweren möchte, weil wir sind natürlich sehr dankbar für jeden von euch, aber diesen Effekt hatte es nicht.
Ja, das ist ganz lustig, weil wir hatten ja tatsächlich die Diskussion vorher, wie wollen wir das machen, wollen wir eventuell ein eigenes Konto einrichten dafür und sagen, okay, damit wir das gut trennen können, haben uns eben, wie Max sagt, bewusst dagegen entschieden, auch in der Hoffnung diesen langfristigen Effekt zu erzielen und was dann aber kam, waren viele Spenden, die ich würde mal sagen im Durchschnitt ungewöhnlich hoch waren oder etwas höher als sonst und wo dann explizit dabei stand, schickt Annika zur WM, für Annika, für die WM. Ja, fand ich ein bisschen amüsant, dass eben das trotzdem zu diesem zweckgebundenen Effekt geführt hat, obwohl wir ihn absichtlich so nicht kommuniziert haben.
Ja, das stimmt allerdings und das ist natürlich generell eine Frage, wie sich die SupporterInnen weiterentwickeln werden. Kurzer Einschub hierzu, wir haben ja da auch mit Paypal und Kreditkarte nochmal einen neuen Weg uns zu unterstützen geschaffen, da ist es jetzt zu früh, dass wir dazu schon etwas sagen könnten. Also wenn ihr euch die Frage gestellt habt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, was hat denn das jetzt gebracht, können wir aktuell noch nicht sagen, aber ich glaube, du würdest mir zustimmen, Frank, die ersten Tendenzen sehen ganz positiv aus.
Sieht gut aus, man sieht, es funktioniert und man bekommt den Eindruck, dass es für viele dienlich ist, weil es eben eine sehr reibungslose Variante ist, mal schnell zu klicken und da es ja eben bei Kreditkarte auch über Google Pay und Apple Pay funktioniert, dass es für viele gerade am Mobilgerät eine schnelle Möglichkeit und ich glaube, das kommt ganz gut an, ob das jetzt unterm Strich dann sich in den Zahlen so bemerkbar macht, werden wir sehen, aber das dauert noch ein bisschen.
Genau, es könnte nämlich auch sein, dass manche jetzt vielleicht den Zahlungsweg ändern. Ich habe schon manchen bekannten Namen gesehen in der Paypal-Unterstützungsliste und deswegen müssen wir das jetzt einfach noch ein bisschen laufen lassen, um da Bilanz zu ziehen. Das wollte ich nur kurz einschieben, aber generelles WM-Fazit sehr, sehr positiv und zwar auch inhaltlich und da möchte ich schon auch nochmal betonen, also auch wenn wir jetzt nicht neue, also nicht wesentlich viele neue UnterstützerInnen durch die ganze WM-Berichterstattung gewonnen haben, ist es aber natürlich auch ein Signal von euch, wenn ihr eben dann uns eine Einmalüberweise macht oder euren bestehenden Betrag aufstockt, denn das zeigt, es gibt nicht nur ideell wollt ihr das unterstützen, sondern es gibt auch ein Interesse daran und das hat man auch an den Sendungen gesehen, am Feedback auf die Sendungen gesehen und es war auch so, ich glaube, das ist jetzt keine Arroganz zu sagen, so wie es im Rasenfunk diese WM-Bericht erstattet wurde, nämlich tatsächlich jedes einzelne Spiel wird analysiert. Es gibt einen ausführlichen Vorschau, es gibt einen ausführlichen Rückblick und wir haben noch versucht im Rahmen, in dem es uns möglich war, da möchte ich nochmal die englischsprachige Tribüngesprächfolge mit Casey empfehlen, haben wir auch versucht den Blick noch zu weiten. So umfassend habe ich es nirgendwo sonst gesehen und das haben wir zwar bei allen anderen Turnieren bisher auch schon gemacht, es lief aber glaube ich noch ein bisschen mehr unterm Radar und es war aber auch eine gute Bestätigung zu sehen, es kommt auch bei euch bestehenden Hörern und Hörern sehr gut an, dass wir sagen, zur WM gehen wir jetzt einen nächsten Schritt und hat es auch leichter gemacht, durch so manchen Zellen-WM-Tags sich so ein bisschen durch zu pushen, das möchte ich ganz persönlich schon so anfügen, denn es ist krass anstrengend, so ehrlich muss man sein. Aber schön, dass es funktioniert hat. Das ist unsere WM-Bilanz, bleibt noch eine Frage, die sicherlich gekommen wäre zu beantworten, nämlich hat sich das denn für euch gelohnt, Frank und Max, den Rasenfunk von einem Einzelunternehmen zu einer GmbH zu machen? Und da ist unsere Antwort unzufrieden.
Wir können eigentlich wenig dazu sagen, vor allem wenig Negatives, das ist glaube ich erstmal das Wichtigste, es hat jetzt erstmal keinen direkten Nachteil, ja die Kosten sind ein bisschen gestiegen, die Steuerberatungskosten sind höher und so, aber das ist alles in dem Maß, wo man das vielleicht jetzt auch nicht zu hoch hängen muss, ansonsten haben wir jetzt noch keinen Jahresabschluss, der jetzt irgendwas konkreter bestätigen würde oder so, aber es sieht erstmal okay aus, im besten Falle soll es ja eigentlich nicht weiter auffallen, weil wir machen Podcasts und kein Business in erster Linie. Insofern, ich glaube für Max ist es erstmal ganz gut, dass er so ein bisschen aus der persönlichen Haftung raus ist. Wir haben ja gleich noch eine andere Neuigkeit, die Max vorhin schon angedeutet hat, die da auch ein bisschen besser mitspielt und ansonsten funktioniert das alles erstmal und hat jetzt keine großen Folgen für uns, keine steuerlichen Vorteile, wie es schon gemutmaßt wurde oder wir erholen auch keinen Investor rein. Also ja, insofern hat sich hoffentlich für euch in diesem Jahr dahingehend nichts zum Negativen geändert durch die GmbH und für uns auch nicht, insofern glaube ich können wir erstmal noch ein bisschen abwarten, bis wir dann ein ganz dickes Fazit daraus ziehen.
Aber Frank, sind wir nicht ein investorengeführter Podcast mit unseren vielen vielen SupporterInnen?
Natürlich. Wir haben halt sehr enge rote Linien. Kein Einzelinvestor und keiner der Supporter ist beteiligt an der GmbH.
Ja und vor allem, wir haben so enge rote Linien, dass es ein Strich ist und da kommt sie nicht drüber, weil ja, ihr könnt uns schon Input schicken, aber mal gucken, was wir damit machen. Nein, also es ist zu früh dazu was zu sagen. Die Kosten sind definitiv gestiegen. Das ist schon, das war uns aber auch vorher klar. Buchherterisch ist das nochmal eine andere Nummer, aber eben das rechtliche Risiko hat Frank angesprochen. Auch generell die ganze Struktur des Rasenfunks. Mir ist einfach jetzt viel viel wohler dabei, seitdem wir eine GmbH sind, weil vorher war es ein Einzelunternehmen. Auf meinen Namen stand und fiel und hätte feilen können mit mir. Dem ist jetzt nicht mehr so und ohne, dass ich da jetzt irgendwelche konkreten Überlegungen oder so hätte.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich würde mal behaupten, dass es immer noch so mag, aber es hat andere Gründe jetzt. Ja, keine geschäftlichen.
Ja gut, aber da käme man jetzt aber auch raus und deswegen und da also ich fühle mich sehr sehr viel wohler.
Zumindest wäre ich im Zweifel geschäftlich handlungsfähig, wenn du es morgen aus irgendeinem Grund nicht sein solltest und das wäre eben vorher nicht so gewesen.
Die Scheißsendung hätte dann schon jemand anders weiter moderiert. Also das ist jetzt alles möglich, ohne dass wir es geplant hätten, aber mir ist viel viel wohler damit und wir werden dazu aber, wenn wir dann auch den Jahresabschluss haben und dann eben auch wissen, welche Kosten sind jetzt wirklich ins letzte Jahr reingefallen, weil da kommen eben welche mit dazu, die wir zum Teil auch noch gar nicht geahnt haben, obwohl wir uns gut vorher informiert haben, dann ziehen wir auch nochmal Bilanz. Ich denke, dass wir das dann im nächsten Rasenfunk Update sicherlich zeigen werden und es wird auch so sein, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, dass wir, wir wissen noch nicht genau in welcher Form, aber wir werden auch auf unserer Webseite ein bisschen einen Einblick geben, was wir mit dem Geld gemacht haben, das wir von euch bekommen haben. Ihr wisst es natürlich eigentlich. Ihr wisst, dass ich davon lebe. Ihr wisst, dass ein kleinerer Anteil auch an Frank geht und ihr wisst, dass vor allem auch die Gäste ein Honorar bekommen. Das kann ich schon sagen, im letzten Jahr waren das 20.000 Euro, die wir an die Gäste gezahlt haben, aber wir wollen das alles schon in einem gewissen Umfang transparent machen. Das wird alles kommen, aber da wäre es jetzt völlig unseriös, wenn ich euch sagen würde, wann und wie das stattfinden wird, denn wir müssen jetzt erstmal den ersten Jahresabschluss einer GmbH in unserer bisherigen Biografie hinter uns bringen. Keine Ahnung, wie lange so was dauert und in welche Phase es dann reinfällt. Wenn wir Pech haben, sind wir damit fertig, wenn der Royal läuft und dann gibt es gar nichts mehr bis nach der EM. Das kann ich euch sagen.
Vor allem ist es ja, glaube ich, für uns alle wichtig und auch für euch, dass wir die Zeit eher nutzen, um an Neuerungen für den Rasenfunk zu arbeiten. Wir haben ja vorgestern in unserer Klausur schon wieder einiges besprochen, was natürlich, wie immer, vor allem mehr Arbeit für Max bedeutet, aber so ist es halt. Da ist er nur gefangen. Aber im Ausgleich dazu gibt es auch Unterstützung für Max, und zwar quasi auch seit dieser Woche.
Seit dieser Woche. Und damit landen wir jetzt quasi im Ankündigungen beziehungsweise Verkündigungsteil. Also wenn euch der ganze Bilanzierungskram nicht interessiert, das ist mir doch egal, wie die alten Männer zurückblicken. Jetzt kommen quasi die freshen News, für die es sich auch lohnt, dann so ein Segment zu hören. Ja, wir haben Frank, unseren ersten freien Mitarbeiter im Rasenfunk, und das seit dieser Woche. Ja, es ist eigentlich zu naheliegend, aber wir wollten dann auch nicht sein Vorname...
Ich bin dafür da, die naheliegend schlechten Witze zu machen.
Ja, wobei ich mich natürlich gegen die E-Mail-Adresse entschieden habe, maxundmoritz.rasenfunk.de.
Als neue Gästebetreuungsteam.
Genau, denn das ist nämlich tatsächlich die Aufgabe von Moritz. Also Moritz, wir freuen uns sehr, dass du mit dabei bist. Diejenigen, die vor unterwegs waren, die haben das ja auch gesehen, willkommen im Rasenfunk, in der Rasenfunk-Familie. Ich nenne jetzt unsere GmbH einfach immer Familie, so machen es doch die Bundesligisten auch immer. Genau, und Uli Hoeneß. Nein, Moment, wie kam ich denn jetzt dazu? Ich weiß auch nicht, ich bin irgendwie falsch abgebogen. Hörtelfleben Folge 17, glaube ich, ist es. Da rede ich da drüber. Aber Moritz wird, und das hat Frank ja gerade schon angedeutet, mich beim Gästemanagement unterstützen, denn das war tatsächlich eins der Felder, das verhindert hat, dass ich mich in der Vergangenheit noch mehr den Inhalten hätte widmen können. Vielleicht auch noch mal ein Tribüngespräch mehr hätte machen können, denn ich habe es vorhin gesagt, 60 Sendungen waren es allein von September bis Dezember. Im Durchschnitt irgendwie 2, irgendwas Gäste. Diese Gäste mussten angefragt werden, es musste einen Termin gefunden werden, denen musste irgendwie dann zum Teil noch Equipment geschickt werden, die Technik erklärt werden, es muss abgesprochen werden, wer schaut welche Spiele und so weiter und so fort. Es war eine schier endlose Reihe und das hat einen großen Teil meiner Zeit gefressen. Und wir hoffen, dass das jetzt dann besser wird, wenn Moritz mich dabei unterstützen kann, manche Dinge dann vielleicht auch ganz selbst übernehmen kann. Und gleichzeitig ist es auch für die Gäste ein Gewinn, denn du hast eben nicht den Max, der wahrscheinlich gerade, wenn du mir schreibst, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ich gerade eine Aufnahme bin, gar nicht so gering. Also ich weiß gar nicht, wie oft ich geschrieben habe, sorry, dass ich mich erst jetzt melde, hatte noch eine Sendung aufzuzeichnen. Das ist schon mal gut, dass wir jetzt jemanden haben, der nicht so viele Sendungen hat, in denen auch wirklich sein Handy dann gar nicht mehr im Blick hat. Also Moritz, wir freuen uns sehr, dass du mit dabei bist. Ganz herzlichen Dank auch an alle anderen, die sich beworben haben. Wir haben euch ja allen nochmal geschrieben und es war keine leichte Entscheidung, auch wenn wir sehr froh sind, dass Moritz jetzt mit dabei ist. Und auch das ist so ein nächster Schritt in der Geschichte des Rasenfunks, dass wir uns jetzt da wirklich mal administrative Unterstützung reinholen.
Ja, es ist vor allem wahrscheinlich auch ein Bereich, den jetzt nicht jeder als Erster genannt hätte, der den Rasenfunk als Hörer kennt. Wenn wir gesagt hätten, wir brauchen Unterstützung, weil es halt etwas ist, was nicht wirklich sichtbar ist, wie viel Aufwand dahinter steckt. Aber ich glaube, du hast es auch in der ein oder anderen Sendung, die wir hier so in der Form veröffentlicht haben in den letzten Jahren, immer schon mal wieder erwähnt, was es eben für eine Arbeit ist, immer die richtigen Gäste zu finden, dann auch die Paarungen immer mal darauf zu gucken, dass der Anteil der weiblichen Gäste auch da ist, dass die auf Absagen zu reagieren, auf kurzfristige Absagen, Ersatz zu finden, etc. Da steckt viel Arbeit drin und natürlich mit jeder Sendung, die mehr veröffentlicht wird, auch mehr Arbeit. Und das ist eben das, was so eine erhöhte Sendungsfrequenz, wie wir sie jetzt mehrfach gesehen haben, dann immer noch mal viel mehr aufwendiger macht.
Und damit sind wir indirekt sogar in einem Part gelandet, den hätten wir jetzt fast vergessen. Frank, Rasenfunkstatistiken, denn wenn der liebe Zaunpfahl schon wirklich viel Zeit investiert, um Statistiken zum Rasenfunk rauszusuchen, dann möchte ich zumindest auch statistisch kurz aufs letzte Jahr zurückblicken. Und wir wissen ja auch, da werde ich so richtig glücklich, wenn ich ein paar Statistiken habe, weil du es gerade genannt hast, zum Beispiel der Frauenanteil-Innsendung im Jahr 2023. Er ist leicht zurückgegangen. Wir waren bei 39, 7 Prozent im Jahr 2022. Und im Jahr 2023 sind wir bei 37, 6 Prozent gelandet. Das heißt noch keine 50, 50, aber wir haben es weiter im Blick. Die Anzahl der Folgen ist krass hochgegangen. Es wird euch nicht überraschen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Es war das produktivste Rasenfunkjahr. Ich glaube, immer weniger von euch da draußen schaffen es wirklich alle Formate zu hören. Ich grüße ganz herzlich diejenigen, die das noch schaffen. Ihr könnt euch sehr gerne mal melden bei uns mitmachen.rasenfunk.de. Oder manche von euch haben ja direkte Kanäle zu mir. Grüße an Pina. Diejenigen, die es noch geschafft haben, alles zu hören. Ich habe dicken Respekt, denn es waren 171 Sendungen in der letzten Saison. Das ist fast 50 Sendungen mehr als in unserer bisher produktivsten Spielzeit. Das war im Jahr 2018.
Krass.
Und es waren insgesamt 310 Stunden Podcasts, die man im letzten Jahr hören konnte. Zaunpfahl hat das ganz wunderbar aufgearbeitet, auch nach Jahren sortiert. Also wenn euch das näher interessiert, dann geht in das Forum und die Kategorie Rasenfunk-News. Und da gibt es den Thread Rasenfunk-Statistiken. Und da ist das sehr, sehr schön aufgearbeitet, auch die Länge der Sendung und so weiter und so fort. Aber es war ein sehr, sehr produktives, sehr, sehr forderndes Jahr. Auch, so ehrlich will ich auch sein. Also jede Sendung ist halt auch Stress, weil auch bei jeder Sendung es ja eine Fallhöhe gibt. Du sagst einmal was über den HSV, was andere Leute anders sehen oder was vielleicht nicht ganz richtig ist. Dann hast du schon mal drei E-Mails und fünf YouTube-Kommentare und alle haben recht. Man denkt sich so, ja, doof, hätte ich mehr Zeit gehabt, hätte ich mir natürlich auch noch mal alles zum HSV durchgelesen, aber wann. Aber ja, es war ein tolles Jahr und ich bin sehr gespannt, wo wir 2024 landen, Frank, mit der EM dann noch. Das wird nochmal was ganz Eigenes. Das wird eine Steigerung werden. Zwei Ankündigungen haben wir jetzt aber noch zu machen. Und zwar einmal, wie immer wollen wir über den Royale reden. Das machen wir, glaube ich, am Schluss. Lass uns erst nochmal kurz über den Kiosk sprechen, Frank. Denn im entferneren Sinne haben wir damit indirekt auch schon bei den Einnahmen und so weiter drüber gesprochen. Die Einnahmen haben sich gut entwickelt für den Rasenfunk, ohne dass wir jetzt eben schon ein Fazit ziehen könnten, weil Geschäftsjahr noch nicht abgeschlossen und so weiter und so fort. Es gibt allerdings einen, na, blinder Fleck ist zu viel, aber einen Aspekt unserer Einnahmenstrategie, der immer schon hinterherhinkt und das ist der Kiosk.
Ja, beim Kiosk hatten wir verschiedene Gedanken irgendwie, um das vielleicht mal kurz so ein bisschen historisch auszuholen. Am Anfang war der Kiosk eigentlich immer angetrieben von Max, muss man sagen. Max hat irgendwann schon den Wunsch geäußert. Ich glaube, wir hatten irgendwann mal mit Aufklebern angefangen. Die hat Max in Umschlägen verschickt. Also ging es los, völlig ohne dafür Geld zu nehmen. Und dann haben wir irgendwann gesagt, na Mensch, es wäre doch toll, wenn wir irgendwie Merchandise hätten. Und was können wir denn da machen und hin und her?
Du vergisst einen Punkt, Frank. Es war schon so weit, dass uns Hörer, ich möchte ganz lieb grüßen an dieser Stelle, dass die uns schon Merch gemacht haben und geschickt haben. Wo wir uns da irgendeinen Weg überlegen mussten, das dann wieder unter die HörerInnen zu bekommen.
Nicht nur geschickt, sondern ich kann mich auch an die Übergabe erinnern beim HörerInnen-Treffen. Nein, das war beim deutschen TK Schland in München. Da erinnere ich mich noch an ein Poloshirt, das ist heute noch im Schrank.
Ich habe es auch heute noch. Aber so weit war es schon und dann haben wir gesagt, na jetzt müssen wir auch noch mal einigen.
Genau, und jetzt müssen wir irgendwann selber was machen. Und dann haben wir es uns natürlich, wie es unsere Natur ist, nicht leicht gemacht, haben nicht die offensichtliche schnelle Variante gewählt, sondern den Deep Dive mit, ja, wir möchten ja möglichst ökologisch produzieren und so. Das könnte alles nachhören, darüber haben wir schon vielfach gesprochen. Dann sind wir in der Zwischenzeit, da erinnere ich mich an irgendeine Sommerklausur in einem Biergarten, haben wir Gedanken gehägt, das eventuell sogar ein bisschen vom Rasenfunk zu entkoppeln, mehr so allgemein coolen Fußballmerch zu machen und hatten verschiedene Ideen dazu. Letztendlich muss man sagen, nichts davon hat so richtig gut funktioniert. Wir sind sehr zufrieden mit den Produkten, Max für die Videozuschauer, an Max seht ihr den Hoodie, der unser letztes großes Produkt jetzt war und wir hatten schon Shirts, wir hatten die dritte Tasse mittlerweile, das dritte Tassendesign, Basecaps und alles mögliche, aber man muss immer dazu sagen, am Ende war es zwar cool, das zu haben und ich trage vor allem den Hoodie selber liebend gern, aber es hat nie funktioniert, daraus eine zweite Unterstützungs-Schiene zu machen, die neben dem eigentlichen Support so richtig funktioniert hat, weil dadurch, dass wir eben den Weg gewählt haben, wie wir es jetzt machen in der Produktion, die Produktion ist einfach wahnsinnig aufwendig. Die Vorbereitung dafür, das Design, das Absprechen der Produkte, wir müssen finanziell sehr stark in Vorleistung gehen, weil wir Stoffbahnen kaufen müssen, aus dem die näher dann die Produkte machen und dann den Druck obendrauf und so weiter. Am Anfang hatten wir selber noch angefangen, das zu verschicken und alles aus meinem Keller damals. Genau und das konnten wir mal auslagern, aber trotz alledem muss man sagen, es war immer okay, es war kein Draufzahlgeschäft, aber es war auch nichts wirklich daran verdient, in einer Form, dass wir sagen können, okay, der zeitliche Einsatz, den wir damit bringen, der zahlt sich aus.
Genau, im Grunde war es bisher so, was wir reingesteckt haben, nee, was wir bekommen haben, haben wir wieder reingesteckt und dann war es manchmal sogar weniger als ein Nullsummenspiel plus das Interesse von euch da draußen ist dann vielleicht doch nicht breit gefächert genug. Also es gibt schon Leute von euch, die sich mit Rasenfunk Merch eingedeckt haben und die sich auch freuen über jedes neue Produkt, aber die Gesamtzahl derjenigen unter euch, die ist dann doch gar nicht so groß, was eben dazu führt, dass wir jetzt schon auf vielen Produkten noch sitzen und wir jetzt die Entscheidung getroffen haben, Frank, der Rasenfunk Kiosk, so wie es ihn jetzt gibt, der wird eingestellt. Das wird noch eine Weile dauern, aber wir verabschieden uns zumindest von dieser Art Merch zu produzieren und haben jetzt aber natürlich noch ein Problem, wir müssen das Lager leer kriegen. Und was haben wir uns da einfallen lassen, Frank? Es ist so innovativ.
Ihr kommt nicht drauf, wenn ihr es hört. Wir werden ab dem Zeitpunkt, wenn ihr diese Sendung hört, alle Produkte, die wir im Lager liegen haben, sprich das sind alle Produkte, die keine sogenannten Print-on-Demand-Produkte sind. Ihr habt im Kiosk, wenn ihr schon mal da wart, wenn nicht, dann bitte schnell, bevor er weg ist, bestimmt auch gesehen, wir haben Poster, die tatsächlich auch ganz beliebt sind und sich ganz gut verkaufen, die haben wir nicht im Lager liegen, die werden auf Bestellung gedruckt und an denen ändert sich nichts, aber alles andere werden wir ab sofort mit 30 Prozent Rabatt versehen und hoffen, dass ihr es uns aus den Händen reißt, denn wie Max schon sagt, wir wollen es loshaben, ganz einfach.
Und man muss auch sagen, die Produkte, die es jetzt gerade im Kiosk noch gibt, also das sind vor allem zwei Tassenmodelle, gibt es noch den Hoodie, das Shirt und die wunderschönen Beanie, das ist, glaube ich, das Rasenfunkprodukt, das ich gegen die Tassen verwendet, inklusive meiner Töchter. Die wird es so nicht mehr geben, also das werden wir nicht nachproduzieren aus ganz diversen Gründen. Es kann sein, dass es irgendwann noch mal eine Form des Rasenfunkmerches gibt, vielleicht überlegen wir uns was für Sticker, wenn ihr sie unbedingt haben wollt, vielleicht fällt uns irgendetwas anderes ein. Wenn ihr zum Beispiel auch schon Erfahrungen habt zu Print-on-Demand-Lösungen, also wo eben quasi jede Bestellung erst dann einen Produktionsprozess auslöst, die ökologisch und auch ökonomisch halbwegs sinnvoll sind, also und vielleicht auch möglichst nachhaltig, schickt sie uns gerne. Wir haben da schon mal recherchiert, das ist jetzt allerdings schon eine ganze Weile her, aber wir wären sehr interessiert daran, denn Print-on-Demand könnten wir jederzeit machen. Wir wollen aber halt gewisse Standards, die wir gerne haben, eben was die Qualität angeht und was eben auch den möglichst fairen Herstellungsprozess angeht, die wollen wir nicht reißen nach unten hin. Wenn ihr da gute Tipps für uns habt, immer her damit. Vielleicht wird das dann unsere neue Lösung, die es dann ab irgendwann geben wird, aber was auf jeden Fall fest steht, ist in diesem Sommer macht der Rasenfunkkios zu und alles, was ihr jetzt da gerade kaufen könnt, was eben nicht die Poster sind oder die Sticker, werdet ihr so nicht nochmal kaufen können und jetzt räumt uns bitte das Lagerlehrer, ansonsten haben wir nämlich eine Anschlussdiskussion, die wir noch führen müssen.
Genau, sonst müssen wir in Zukunft Garagen anmieten und die Sachen da unterzustellen. Nur solange der Vorrat reicht, kiosk.rasenfunk.de.
Mit dem Rabattcode, nee.
Vielleicht mit Rabattcode. Unter Umständen, wenn ihr jetzt dieses Video guckt, dann seht ihr vielleicht ein Rabattcode, weil wir wissen noch gar nicht so ganz, wie das...
Oh Gott, muss ich den einblenden, Frank? Nein, da steht eine Videobeschreibung, Leute. Kommt, das schafft ihr.
Und wenn ihr schon da unten seid, dann lasst einen Like da.
Für jede Einblende muss ich einen eigenen Track anlegen bei Ultraschall. Das heißt, ich müsste dann quasi dann ein Video nur an der Stelle rausklippen, dann den Effekt Videoanblendung rüberlegen und das dann...
Ja, okay, klingt einfach.
Genau. Habe ich nicht vorhin noch gesagt, ich will es nur monetär machen. Das ist der Grund dafür. Also, das ist eine der großen Ankündigungen, neben eben dem, dass wir jetzt Moritz mit im Team haben. Und dann gibt es noch ein letztes Thema, über das wir mit euch sprechen wollen und das ist Trommelwirbel... Der Rasenfunk-Royal. Oje, Frank, wir muten unseren Hörerinnen vor allem...
Das Lustige, ich glaube, ich habe in der letzten Sendung dieser Art dir damit gedroht, dass wir über den Royal noch sprechen müssen.
Aber da konntest du schon sehen, dass ich genickt habe. Gott sei Dank kann man da schon ein Video aufgenommen.
Weiß ich gar nicht mehr so genau. Aber das Lustige ist, dass du jetzt bei der Klausur vor zwei Tagen du mit dem Thema angefangen hast und nicht ich, was sehr gut war.
Also, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wir wissen, dass Veränderungen immer schwierig sind, aber ihr habt die Feedumstellung geschafft. Ihr werdet vielleicht auch so manches andere, was wir auch mal so testweise jetzt verändern werden, hinbekommen. Feedback dazu immer gerne ins Forum geben. Stichwort eben zum Beispiel der Beginn von so mancher Sendung. Mal gucken, wie sich das weiterentwickelt. Ihr werdet auch das jetzt schaffen. Den Rasenfunk-Royal, wie es ihm bisher gab. Und damit meine ich nicht, dass über jeden Verein gesprochen wird. Das wird bleiben. Aber die Verpackung, nämlich, dass das sechs große Sendungen waren, ah, vier bis fünfeinhalb Stunden. Und dass da zum Teil auch Vereine miteinander vermengt wurden in Gesprächsrunden, die vielleicht... Manchmal gab es da wunderbare Brücken, die man bauen konnte. Manchmal war es aber einfach nur Zufall. Die lagen halt nebeneinander in der Tabelle. Oder, ich wusste, die Gäste verstehen sich gut. Die Verpackung des Royals, sie wird sich verändern. Wir werden in dieser Saison diesen Royal erstmalig anders machen. Und es wird aber auch einen Vorteil haben. Also, es wird nicht mehr so sein. An einem Tag erscheinen sechs Teile. Die sind dann insgesamt 24 Stunden lang. Oder ich glaube, das letzte Mal waren sogar 28 Stunden. Und ihr könnt die dann durchhören, so wie ihr wollt. Sondern es werden viel mehr Teile. Wir werden es aufteilen, so wie wir jetzt auch schon die Schwerpunkte machen. Das heißt, es gibt dann pro Verein einen Saisonrückblick. Die große Herausforderung wird sein, da dann die Zeit nicht zu überschreiten. Denn ihr wisst es ja, für euch sind es dann, ach Gott, es war ja nur eine Stunde, eine Stunde insgesamt. Aber für mich sind es ja 18 Stunden mit 18 Gästen und so weiter und so fort. Plus Postproduktion und so weiter. Es wird wahrscheinlich auch noch übergeordnete Teile geben, wie wir das genau machen, wissen wir nicht. Und was aber der große Vorteil sein wird, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ich habe einen großen Vorteil und ihr habt einen großen Vorteil. Mein großer Vorteil ist, wenn wir die Gesprächsrunden auflösen, dann kann ich die Terminplanung des Rasenfunks schon vor dem 34. Spieltag machen. Bisher war es nämlich so, 34. Spieltag ab Pfiff, dann Saisonrückblick, also die normale Sendung, die früher mal Schlusskonferenz hieß. Wir alle wissen, die dauert ungefähr vier Stunden. Die lade ich dann noch nachts hoch. Irgendwann nachts um drei falle ich ins Bett. Und manchmal habe ich dann noch nachts die Terminplanung gemacht und manchmal erst am nächsten Morgen sehr früh, weil dann erst haben alle Rasenfunks-Gäste ihren Aufnahmeslot bekommen. Die mussten vorher ein riesiges Terminumfrage-Dokument ausführen und alle Verfügbarkeiten eintragen und ich habe dann die Gesprächsrunden und so weiter daraus zusammen glambüset. Und erst dann hatte jeder und jede ihren und seinen Termin und erst dann konnte ich mit dem Aufnehmen beginnen. Das war ein höllischer Aufwand, der zu tausenden Problemen geführt hat. Das wird sich jetzt verändern. Jetzt kann ich früher planen, weil ich ja weiß, ich nehme mit jedem einzeln auf, dann brauche ich nur die Verfügbarkeiten und baue mir dann mein Ding zusammen. Und das ist mein Vorteil und für euch der Vorteil, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, haben wir darüber diskutiert. In der Klausurtagung müsste man das jetzt dann eigentlich noch zu einem festen Termin veröffentlichen. Nee, eigentlich nicht. Eigentlich ist doch jeder Saisonrückblick dann, wenn er fertig ist, fertig. Es ist sogar vom Vorteil, weil manchmal hatten wir das ja noch, dass dann jemand seinen Trainer noch entlassen hat, bevor der Royale erschienen ist, aber schon nachdem das entsprechende Vereinssegment aufgezeichnet war. Also der Royale wird früher kommen und er wird häppchenweise kommen und vielleicht ist das ja dann ja auch eine gute Nachricht für euch da draußen.
Ich finde es gut. Ich glaube auch, dass es gut ankommen wird. Es zahlt wieder so ein bisschen ein in diese Richtung, über die wir vorher schon gesprochen haben, die bessere Auffindbarkeit. Man hat dann eben eine klare Sendungssaisonrückblick Heidenheim und einen klaren Fokus. Hilft uns an der Stelle auch, glaube ich, was eben die Sichtbarkeit angeht. Hilft aber auch den Hörern oder vielleicht auch neuen Hörern, die bei YouTube oder auch in den Podcatchern gezielt nach ihrem Verein suchen, dann auch diesen Saisonrückblick dort punktgenauer zu finden. Und außerdem ist es auch für die Zusatzsegmente im Royale, sei es jetzt unser Gespräch, dass wir da jedes Jahr angedockt haben, das muss da ja nicht hin.
Ja, das wird im Zukunft immer ein Tribüngespräch sein, Frank.
Genau, es wird ein Tribüngespräch sein und es muss dann auch nicht dringend noch schnell zwischen Saisonabschluss und Royale-Veröffentlichung aufgenommen werden, sondern kann eben auch ein bisschen losgelöst davon sein, genauso wie vielleicht Taktik- oder Schiedsrichter-Segmente.
Ja, und man muss eben auch nicht mehr auf den Relegationsteilnehmer warten, der in der Regel dann in der Liga geblieben ist. Das hat ja bisher den Veröffentlichungszeitpunkt des Royales diktiert. Es war immer am Tag nach dem Relegationsrückspiel der ersten Liga natürlich und alles andere musste bis dahin fertig sein, dann ganz schnell möglichst einen Gast finden, der dann auch die Zeit hat, entweder nachts noch aufzunehmen oder möglichst früh am Tag, damit dann eben auch bis Abend alles online ist, weil allein der Veröffentlichungsprozess des Royales, der hat immer so rund drei Stunden gedauert.
Und mir ist auch definitiv wohler, weil der Grund, warum ich gesagt habe, wir müssen über den Royale reden, war ja eigentlich immer dein Stresslevel in dieser Zeit. Und da besteht jetzt zumindest ein bisschen Aussicht darauf, dass das ein kleines bisschen einfacher wird.
Das denke ich auch. Also ich glaube, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, auch das wird eine Entscheidung sein, wo wir dann im Nachhinein sagen, so wie schon bei der Feedumstellung, hätte man eigentlich schon früher so machen können, weil die Vorteile, die Nachteile dann doch überwiegen. Und ihr könnt ja trotzdem noch alles nacheinander weghören. Das ist euch ja völlig frei überlassen. Also der Royale wird anders aussehen. Und dann, da können wir jetzt noch nichts konkret ankündigen, aber dann wartet die EM auf uns. Ich glaube, ich kann für uns beide sprechen, Frank, dass wir uns da einfach sehr drauf freuen, dass wir extrem gespannt darauf sind, wie dieses Turnier ankommen wird, sowohl eben bei unseren Hörerinnen, auch generell die Berichterstattung, wie die sein wird. Wir werden natürlich wieder versuchen, es allumfassend zu besprechen. Also es wird wieder Vorschau, Rückblick geben, es wird tägliche Sendungen geben, aber die genaue Form wissen wir noch nicht, weil man so ehrlich sein muss, dadurch, dass dieses Turnier in Deutschland stattfindet und dadurch, dass es dann eine theoretische Möglichkeit für mich zum Beispiel gibt, bei Spielen vor Ort zu sein. Vielleicht ist die UEFA gnädig und akkreditiert mich für Deutschland gegen Schottland hier in München. Das wäre natürlich ganz fantastisch. Wann zeichnen wir dann die Sendung auf? Habe ich da gutes Internet? Wird da auch noch Video mitgeliefert? Keine Ahnung, das alles muss ich erst noch zeigen, aber ich glaube, wir freuen uns auf die EM. Das könnte auch ein sehr schöner, na nicht Abschluss, ist ja Quatsch, wir schließen nichts ab, aber so ein bisschen sind diese Turniere ja immer schon wichtig gewesen für den Rasenfunk. Wir hatten immer verschiedene Peaks, was quasi so Treppenstufen waren, wo wir unsere Reichweite erhöht haben. Das war immer der Rasenfunk-Royal und das waren immer Turniere. Und jetzt ist es eben seit einigen Jahren so, dass wir diese Treppenstufen nicht mehr sehen. Also wir machen dann eben zur WM 2018, die damals sehr, sehr umfangreiche Berichterstattung sehen, aber nicht mehr, dass sich dadurch jetzt wirklich so viele neue Menschen bei uns einfinden. Und vielleicht könnte die EM davon die Ausnahme sein mit allen Dingen, die wir vorher auch besprochen haben. Und generell muss ich auch sagen, ich freue mich auch einfach auf dieses Turnier, unabhängig davon, wie weit die Deutschen kommen, weil ich einfach sehr gespannt darauf bin, schafft das vielleicht auch die deutsche Öffentlichkeit, sich einfach an einem Turnier zu erfreuen, selbst wenn es vielleicht für das Heimteam nicht so gut läuft. Das könnte schon gut werden.
Ja, definitiv. Da bin ich auch sehr gespannt darauf, wie so ein bisschen die Gesellschaft damit umgeht. Auch fast 20 Jahre zurückblickend auf die WM im eigenen Land, wie sich die Dinge da verändert haben und wie der heutige Umgang damit ist.
Ja, und bei der ja auch wirklich vieles nicht gut war. Also ich habe jetzt erst neulich wieder einen Podcast gehört, wo es auch kurzzeitig um die WM 2006 ging und wo wieder nur das Sommerbällchen erwähnt wurde und nicht erwähnt wurde, wie eben mit Argentinien umgegangen wurde oder dann mit in Deutschland lebenden Menschen mit italienischen Wurzeln. Es war nicht alles toll zur WM 2006 und ich glaube, dass wir diese Schattenseiten sehr, sehr viel deutlicher jetzt bei diesem Turnier sehen werden. Einfach weil soziale Netzwerke die Art und Weise verändert haben, wie über solche Dinge berichtet werden.
Ich glaube, es ist viel mehr das hervorheben.
Es ist eine höhere Sichtbarkeit da. Wahrscheinlich ist dann auch die Herausforderung, das nicht über zu betonen, sich da nicht so sehr mitreißen zu lassen von den Extrembeispielen, die es ganz sicher 2006 auch gab, die wir aber ganz sicher damals oft nicht gesehen haben. Aber deswegen, ich bin sehr gespannt darauf und ich könnte da auch selber noch keine Prognose abgeben. Ich weiß nur, dass ich mich unheimlich darauf freue. Ich habe natürlich enormen Bammel davor, wie wir das alles hinbekommen, dieses Turnier zu stemmen. Aber das haben wir bisher noch immer gewuppt bekommen. Das wird diesmal auch klappen. Also EM 2024. Wir sind noch nicht ganz bereit, aber wir freuen uns schon drauf. Letzte Worte, Frank. Was haben wir noch nicht angesprochen? Was möchtest du den HörerInnen noch mitgeben?
Ich glaube, inhaltlich fehlt mir nichts. Ich wollte vielleicht noch mal so zurückblickend auf das letzte Jahr einfach noch mal Danke sagen für den großartigen Support. Die Zeiten sind gerade gefühlt, sagen wir das auch seit vielen Jahren, zunehmend schwerer so ein bisschen gesamtgesellschaftlich, auch wirtschaftlich für viele schön zu sehen, dass ihr uns trotzdem weiter unterstützt, dass der Bereich trotzdem sich für uns gut entwickelt und uns darin bestärkt, dass wir auf dem richtigen Weg sind. Ich hoffe, das bleibt auch in Zukunft so. Im Vorblick auf die EM vielleicht auch da die Bitte an euch, uns zu unterstützen. Nicht nur finanziell, natürlich finanziell, aber auch im Forum inhaltlich.
Ja, sehr gerne.
Haut damit rein. Sagt uns gern, wie ihr auf die EM blickt, wie ihr euch darauf freut, was ihr eventuell selber zu EM macht. Wollt ihr schauen, dass ihr Karten bekommt? Seid ihr vor Ort? Wollen wir sehr gern hören und mit eurem Input arbeiten. Definitiv.
Input auf der einen Seite und aber auch sehr gerne hier noch mal der Hinweis, empfehlt uns bitte weiter. Es kommt zu einer Floskel, sagt einem auch jeder Influencer da draußen, aber es ist eben nun mal die beste Form, in der man wachsen kann. Also wir haben alle möglichen Arten schon durchprobiert. Auftritte in anderen Formaten, Auftritte im Fernsehen und so weiter und so fort. Das immer am besten funktionierende Mittel, um neue HörerInnen zu gewinnen, ist die persönliche Empfehlung. Also nehmt es zum Anlass, packt euch eine Sendung, die euch besonders gefallen hat. Schickt die jemanden, empfehlt den YouTube-Kanal, wenn ihr möchtet. Das wäre schön. Ihr könnt es auch gerne bewerten auf den Plattformen, wo das möglich ist. Die Podcast-Landschaft, sie hat sich wirklich krass verändert, auch und gerade im Bereich Sport und Fußball und das wird mit der EM 2024 noch extremer werden. Wir können nicht mehr damit rechnen, dass allein dadurch, dass wir über jedes Spiel sprechen, wir gefunden werden. Wahrscheinlich wird eher das Gegenteil der Fall sein. Vielleicht sind wir sogar auch gar nicht mehr alleine mit diesem Ansatz. Wer weiß das schon. Also ihr könnt weiter unsere wichtigsten Influencer sein, indem ihr andere auf den Rasenfunk aufmerksam macht und vielleicht auch jene, bei denen ihr das schon mal gemacht habt, die aber gesagt haben, ich habe keine Zeit für drei Stunden Sendung. Vielleicht haben sie für manches unsere neuen Formate dann doch die Zeit, denn es ist ein bisschen zumindest kompakter geworden, ohne dass der Inhalt gelitten hätte.
Kompakt, genau.
Eigentlich ist es ja sogar länger geworden, wir haben es nur getrennt. Das war sehr schlau.
Sagen wir einfach, zugänglicher ist es geworden. Genau und da gibt es auch diesen Thread im Forum dazu, den wir im letzten Jahr als Input genutzt haben, der dann letztendlich zu den Feedänderungen geführt hat. Guckt da gerne rein ins Forum, wenn ihr Ideen habt, was wir noch tun können, um neue Hörer zu gewinnen. Dort ist der richtige Ort, uns das zu sagen.
Oh je, ich muss ganz viele Links setzen und ich hoffe, dass ich das nicht vergessen habe, weil die Links werde ich erst setzen, nachdem ich jetzt gleich die PK mit mir Künstler gesehen habe. Also ich schreibe mir mal lieber auf, dass ich da nochmal ins Forum gucken muss. Also hoffentlich ist alles verlinkt, was euch interessiert.
Alle Links unten in der Beschreibung bzw.
Alle Links, an die ich mich erinnert habe. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, es war ein wunderbares Jahr 2023 mit euch und es wird ein ganz fantastisches Jahr 2024. Anders kann es gar nicht sein, so wie die Zeichen stehen. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Danke dir, lieber Frank. Du weißt, wie immer, es ist ein Highlight für mich, mit dir gemeinsam hier zu sprechen.
Schön, dass ich wieder dabei sein durfte.
Ja, mal gucken, wann wir dann dieses Rasenfunk-Update das nächste Mal machen. Das wird natürlich nochmal die Frage, aber wir finden einen Termin und dann werden wir... Genau, irgendwann danach. Geht in den Kiosk, kauft den leer. Frank, mach's gut, bis bald.
Reißt uns das Zeug aus der Hand.
Ja, aber wirklich. Es wäre wirklich notwendig. Danke euch, danke auch für euren Support. Wir hören uns bald hier wieder und jetzt geht's wieder los. Das ist die erste Sendung im Jahr 2024 und jetzt könnt ihr euch darauf einstellen. Das rattert jetzt so durch. 68 Sendungen bis zur M-Funk-Show ohne Rasenfunk-Royale. Also, ich hoffe, eure Ohren sind gut geölt. Macht's gut, ciao.
Das war der Rasenfunk. Wir geben nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.